in other videos we have talked about how
the other branches of government can
limit supreme court powers we're going
to continue that conversation in this
video by discussing how the amendment
process can also limit or overrule a
supreme court decision
so let's go to
1875.
just for some context the 14th amendment
the united states had already been
ratified and in particular you have the
privileges or immunities clause of the
14th amendment that says no state shall
make or enforce any law which shall
abridge the privileges or immunities of
citizens of the united states
well you could imagine a lot of women at
the time who were citizens of the united
states said that look voting is a
privilege of being a citizen but i am
not allowed to vote
and so you have virginia minor who was a
citizen in missouri decides to register
to vote she is denied and eventually
takes the registrar to court it
eventually gets appealed all the way to
the united states supreme court in minor
versus haperset where haperset is the
registrar in missouri and the supreme
court in this case rules that voting is
not a privilege of citizenship for women
and it seems absurd to us right now that
voting seems to be one of the main
privileges of being a citizen but that's
the way the supreme court ruled in 1875.
now the folks who were fighting for a
women's right to vote weren't just women
they were also men eventually started to
have victories in the early 1900s at
various states especially states in the
west started to allow women to vote but
as we go into the teens of the 1900s
with the movement gets enough steam to
get congress and the state legislators
to propose and ratify the 19th amendment
which says
the right of citizens of the united
states to vote shall not be denied or
abridged by the united states or by any
state on account of sex congress shall
have power to enforce this article by
appropriate legislation
so what we have here is the legislative
branch both the u.s congress and the
state legislatures because it needs to
be voted for by two-thirds of both
houses of congress and then ratified by
three-fourths of the states they
essentially overruled the minor versus
happier set decision they said all right
supreme court you might see some
ambiguity in the 14th amendment although
today it's hard to say that voting isn't
a privilege of citizenship but to make
it very clear they proposed and ratified
the 19th amendment
so not only is this an interesting time
in american history not that long ago
less than a hundred years before this
video that i'm making was made women did
not have the full right to vote in most
of the united states we eventually get
the 19th amendment but of above and
beyond that this is an example of how
other branches of government can
exercise some checks on the united
states supreme court